AS THE KNIVES COME OUT FOR JOE,
ONE MUST ASK WHO IS WORSE, THE
MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS RUSHING TO
DEFEND THE GUY OR THE MEDIA AND
DEMOCRATS RUSHING TO CONDEMN
HIM.
YOU CAN HOLD THESE TO THOUGHTS.
BIDEN HAS ACTED STRANGE AND YES,
IT'S A CALCULATED HIT TO GET HIM
OUT OF THE RACE BY HIS OWN SIDE.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT COACHING
WOMEN BUT BEING AN OLD WHITE MAN
WHICH FOR THE LEFT IS WORSE THAN
A WAR CRIMINAL.
HOW CAN BIDEN'S PEOPLE NOT THIS
COMING?
THE PROOF IS LIKE BIDEN'S HANDS
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
AS NANCY PELOSI PUT IT.
>> HE'S AN INFECTION IN PERSON.
TO CHILDREN, SENIOR CITIZENS,
EVERYONE.
THAT'S JUST SO HE IS.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE.
HE TOUCHES MORE PEOPLE THAN MOST
CHIROPRACTORS.
PELOSI'S ADVICE?
>> JUST PRETEND YOU HAVE A COLD
AND I HAVE A COLD.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: HOW IS THAT FOR ME
TOO ADVICE?
THERE ARE THOSE COMPLAINING THAT
JOE IS BEING WRONGLY ACCUSED.
>> IS THIS REALLY WHERE WE WANT
TO GO WITH ME TOO?
HE'S A NICE GUY.
HE'S NOT A PREDATOR.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
LET ME SAY IT.
YOU ARE AIDING THOSE WHO CAN BE
TRUMP.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF WE WILL SEE
ANYMORE SMELLING OF HAIR OR
KISSES.
>> THAT PISSES ME OFF.
I DON'T WANT JOE TO STOP DOING
THAT.
>> I DON'T EITHER.
>> Greg: HAIR DOES SMELL GOOD.
SORRY, JOE FANS, THIS PATH
FORWARD IS THE ONE THAT MANY OF
YOU HELP BLAISE.
EVEN IF BIDEN IS GUILTY OF
CLUMSY AFFECTION, THE ACCUSERS
MUST BE HEARD AND BELIEVED NO
MATTER HOW LONG AGO IT HAPPENED,
BECAUSE BIDEN'S OWN PARTY
DEMANDS IT.
DUE PROCESS, IF YOU REMEMBER,
WAS SEXIST.
THEY MADE THAT CLEAR MONTHS AGO
AND HEARING OVER SOME GUY NAMED
BRETT.
NO COINCIDENCE COMPLAINTS COMING
FORWARD NOW.
WHEN BIDEN WASN'T IN THE WAY AND
NO ONE CARED, FRIENDLY, GOOFY
JOE.
NOW HE'S JUST HANGING AROUND SO
HE'S GOT TO GO.
WHEN YOU ARE NO LONGER WANTED BY
THOSE WHO WANT POWER FOR
THEMSELVES, THEY WILL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO PUT THEIR ARMS
AROUND YOUR SHOULDERS, SMILED,
AND THEN WALK YOU INTO TRAFFIC.
ALL RIGHT, JUAN, I HAVE A
THEORY.
THIS IS MY DEFENSE OF JOE BIDEN.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY SAID THIS
BUT MY THEORY IS THE GUY'S BEEN
THROUGH HELL, LOST HIS WIFE, A
DAUGHTER IN A CAR ACCIDENT, LOST
HIS SON.
COULD THE AFFECTION THAT HE
SHOWS BE A VOW TO SHOW
APPRECIATION TO THE LIVING
BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW IF
THEY'LL BE THERE TOMORROW.
THAT'S MY THEORY.
>> Greg: CAN I LEAP ACROSS THE
TABLE AND HUG YOU?
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
MY HAIR DOES NOT SMELL GOOD.
NOT AFTER THIS WEEKEND.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: WE'LL CLEAN YOU UP.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW HIS PSYCHOLOGY BUT
I CAN TELL YOU WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING FROM PELOSI AND OTHERS
IS TRUE.
HE IS A TOUCHY-FEELY, EMPATHETIC
GUY WITH GUYS AND WITH WOMEN.
SENATOR COONS OF DELAWARE WHO IS
HIS SUCCESSOR IN THE SENATE SAID
THERE WERE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
JOE HAD WHISPERED INTO HIS
13-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER'S EAR.
THE LITTLE GIRL SAID JOE WAS
TELLING HER THAT SHE WAS
HANDLING THE MOMENT WELL.
IF YOU ARE A CRITIC, AND
YESTERDAY ON THE SHOW, THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SAYING THIS IS AN
OPPOSITION DUMP ON JOE'S HEAD
FROM DEMOCRATS WERE TRYING TO
GET HIM, PREEMPT HIM BEFORE HE
GETS IN THE RACE.
MY TAKE, ESPECIALLY AFTER
LISTENING TO YOUR MONOLOGUE IS,
I THINK REPUBLICANS ARE STILL
UPSET ABOUT KAVANAUGH, STILL
UPSET ABOUT QUESTIONS ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO SAID HE WAS
GOING TO GRAB WOMEN IN THEIR
PRIVATE AND SAYING WELL,
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL,"
YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE EXCUSES AND
APOLOGIES FROM BEING A PALE
MALE.
THEY SAY IDENTITY POLITICS.
IT'S INTERESTING TO WATCH
BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO GO ON
ALL THROUGH THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARIES.
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO
BE TWEETING, WE ARE GOING TO BE
TALKING AND YOU HAVE ALL THESE
DEMOCRATS UP THERE THROWING
PUNCHES, HAYMAKERS AT EACH OTHER
AND THIS MAY BE ONE OF THEM.
>> Greg: JESSE, I DON'T THINK
REPUBLICANS CARE THAT MUCH ABOUT
THIS.
>> Jesse: WE ARE JUST
DELIGHTING IN IT.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHAT I THINK
GREAT >> Jesse: CONSERVATIVES
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THESE
VIDEOS AND RE-TWEETING THEM FOR
ABOUT TEN YEARS.
WE HEAR FROM BERNIE, THIS OP
DUMP.
HE LEARNED HOW TO PLAY DIRTY
FROM HILLARY BECAUSE HE'S NOT
GOING TO GO DOWN WITHOUT A
FIGHT.
SOME PERSPECTIVE, HE IS A CREEPY
GUY WHO LIKES TO NUZZLE BUT HE
IS NOT BILL COSBY.
HE CROSSED THE LINE AND HE
SHOULD APOLOGIZE AND THAT'S
FINE.
THE MEDIA HAD A HUGE HAND IN
THIS.
THE MEDIA CREATED POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE USING
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS AGAINST
EACH OTHER AND THE MEDIA IS
SITTING AROUND EXASPERATED,
SAYING YOU ARE TRYING TO TAKE
DOWN THE WRONG GUY -- TAKE DOWN
THE ONE GUY WHO CAN WIN.
THE FACT THAT CONSERVATIVES HAVE
BEEN JOKING ABOUT BIDEN FOR TEN
YEARS, THE MEDIA NEVER COVERED
IT.
BY TRYING TO PROTECT JOE BIDEN,
THE MEDIA ENDS UP HURTING
JOE BIDEN.
IF THE MEDIA COVERED THIS FOR
THE LAST TEN YEARS, BIDEN COULD
HAVE ADDRESSED IT AND IT
COULD'VE BEEN DIGESTED AND WE
COULD'VE MOVED ON.
THEY TRY TO COVER REPUBLICAN
WEAKNESSES AND COVER UP FOR
DEMOCRATS.
THE DEMOCRAT GETS OUT THERE HE'S
NOT INVITING SHAPE AND HE'S
RUSTY AND HE GETS BODY SLAMMED
BEFORE HE ANNOUNCES.
MY FAVORITE PART ABOUT THIS
THING IS DON LEMON'S DEFENSE OF
THIS.
DON LEMON SAID THIS AND I WANT
EVERYBODY TO REMEMBER THIS THE
NEXT TIME I GET IN TROUBLE.
DON'T APOLOGIZE.
NOBODY'S PERFECT.
I'M GOING TO KEEP THAT ONE OF MY
BACK POCKET NEXT TIME CNN IS
DEMANDING A REPUBLICAN RESIGN OR
APOLOGIZE.
THROUGHOUT THE DON LEMON
DEFENSE.
>> Greg: UNINTENTIONALLY
HILARIOUS MONOLOGUE FROM
DON LEMON.
OR MAYBE IT WAS INTENTIONALLY.
I DON'T KNOW.
DANA.
THESE PEOPLE DEFENDING JOE,
SHOULD I DO THE -- SHOULD I SAY
WHAT IF IT WERE A REPUBLICAN?
>> Dana: I GET IT.
I DON'T LIKE "WHAT ABOUT-ISM."
I DON'T LIKE IT.
SORRY.
>> Jesse: IT LEAVES ME WITHOUT
A LOT TO SAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: YOU DID PLENTY AND
YOU DID VERY WELL.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU.
WAIT TILL THE B BLOCK.
>> Dana: HERE'S THE THING.
IT OBVIOUSLY IS A CALCULATED
ATTACK FROM HIS SIDE.
THEY KNEW HE WAS WAITING UNTIL
APRIL TO ANNOUNCE.
THE THING ABOUT BIDEN IS IF
YOU'RE GOING TO RUN AGAINST
THESE CHARACTERS -- I'M NOT EVEN
TALKING ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO RUN IN THIS
PRIMARY, YOU'VE GOT TO BE READY.
HE HAS NO CAMPAIGN APPARATUS TO
DEAL WITH IT.
THIS STORY HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
A WEEK AND THEY DON'T REALLY
HAVE A WAY TO DEAL WITH IT.
HE SEEMS CAUGHT BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
>> Jesse: HIS SURROGATES WERE
THE MEDIA.
DIDN'T HAVE ANYBODY OUT THERE ON
HIS OWN SIDE.
>> Katie: THE WAY HE'S DEALT
WITH IT IS HAVING HIS
SPOKESPERSON BLAME REPUBLICANS
FOR THE ALLEGATION THAT CAME OUT
EVEN THOUGH IT CAME FROM A
DEMOCRATIC WOMAN WHO HE
INAPPROPRIATELY TOUCHED.
IT'S CLEARLY AN ATTACK BECAUSE
SHE IS SAYING I WILL STILL
OBVIOUSLY VOTE FOR JOE BIDEN
OVER DONALD TRUMP IF HE WINS THE
PRIMARY.
BY THE WAY, IT WASN'T A SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
IT WAS JUST INAPPROPRIATE
TOUCHING AND I'M LETTING
EVERYBODY KNOW ABOUT IT.
THE LEFT PUT THEMSELVES IN THIS
CORNER INTO THIS BOX ON THE
QUESTION NOW IS WHETHER THEY ARE
GOING TO PLAY BY THEIR OWN
RULES.
I AGREE WITH GREG.
JOE BIDEN HAS DONE SOME WEIRD
STUFF.
THE THING NOW IS EVERYONE IS
COMING OUT AND SAYING MY
EXPERIENCE WITH HIM IS NOT THAT.
ALYSSA MILANO WAS ONE OF THEM.
YOU SHOULD BELIEVE ME WHEN I SAY
HE'S A GOOD GUY WHO RESPECTS
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
BUT THAT WAS NOT THE CASE WHEN
IT CAME TO BRETT KAVANAUGH.
THEY SMEARED HIS FAMILY AND WHEN
THE TRUTH CAME OUT ABOUT HIM
WHICH WAS 100-PLUS PAGES OF A
SENATE REPORT SHOWING NOT A
SINGLE ACCUSATION AGAINST HIM
HAD ANY EVIDENCE AT ALL AND
PEOPLE WERE REFERRED FOR
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION FOR LYING
AND ISSUING FALSE ACCUSATIONS TO
SENATE INVESTIGATORS WHO ARE
LOOKING INTO THIS.
THE MICHAEL AVENATTI MAKING
THESE CLAIMS.
THEY IGNORE THAT REPORT
COMPLETELY.
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUTISM NOW.
>> Greg: ALYSSA MILANO SITTING
BEHIND KAVANAUGH LIKE A JUDGE,
JURY, EXECUTIONER.
SHE MAKES ME WANT TO ROOT
AGAINST BIDEN.
>> Juan: THIS IS INCREDIBLE TO
ME.
THIS IS ABOUT YOU, JESSE, OR
IT'S ABOUT KAVANAUGH?
OR IT'S ABOUT HOW REPUBLICANS
ARE BEING UNFAIRLY CHARGED WITH
PUSHING THIS ONE IT'S ACTUALLY
DEMOCRATS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT JOE BIDEN BUT I
THINK IT SHOULD BE ABOUT
JOE BIDEN AND YOU KNOW WHAT,
EVEN JOE BIDEN SAID THE ACCUSER
SHOULD BE HEARD AMIDST THE
KAVANAUGH THING.
>> Katie: BRETT KAVANAUGH SAID
THAT AS WELL.
>> Dana: WHEN I GOT SWORN INTO
THE BROADCASTING BOARD OF
GOVERNORS, I GOT A NICE HUG FROM
JOE BIDEN ON MY REMEMBER IT
FONDLY.
SO THEY      THEY ARE.
>> Greg: HOWELL FONDLY, DANA?
>> Katie: DID HE SMELL YOUR
HAIR?
>> Dana: I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Greg: YOUR HAIR DOES SMELL
GOOD.
WHEN I HUG ANYONE, THE HEIGHT
RATIO MAKES IT AWKWARD.
IF I CAME UP BEHIND ANYBODY, MY
NOSE WOULD BE IN THEIR SHOULDER
BLADES.
>> Juan: WASN'T THERE A
HOLLYWOOD STORE WHO REFUSED TO
HUG SOMEBODY?
>> Katie: IT WAS SEINFELD.